iego is a Phoenix City Councilmember
she's running for mayor in that city and
she supports the continuation of daca
she joins us tonight
okaygo thanks for joining us appreciate
it thank you so much for having me so
trying to think through how legalizing
people who are here illegally helps
American citizens in in Arizona we have
some data on this because it the state
passed as you know one of the toughest
anti-immigration laws in the country in
2010 and the effects that have been
studied and here's what they showed
there was a short-term labor shortage
obviously people here to work they can't
work there was a labor shortage but
overtime automation made up for it and
wages went up for American workers costs
meanwhile went down prison costs went
down education cost went down
dramatically but hundreds of millions of
dollars so given that we know that why
does it help the economy to legalize
people here illegally right now the City
of Phoenix is the fastest growing city
in the entire country we added more
people in 2016 than on any other city
and we're constrained by our workforce
right now we just had some folks from
the homebuilding industry come into the
City of Phoenix and say we could do so
much more if we had a larger
construction workforce we could be
creating jobs we could building built
building new affordable homes for people
to live in but we don't have the
workforce we need and they said that the
point that they really feel like it's
changed was not having enough people
through immigration yeah ya know a lot
of employers make that case and they
mean it they want obviously cheaper
labor I think all employers do why
wouldn't they but if that's true if more
illegal immigrants make a place richer
then how many specifically do you think
Arizona or Phoenix needs how many
illegals do you need in your city to
make it richer would more be better
about 10 million would that make it even
richer right now we are desperately
concerned about our daca recipients who
are in our city Arizona has 28,000 daca
recipients who have been great members
of our community who went to our high
schools were educated here we've been
investing in them for years now they're
ready to give back and we're worried
about their future right now
our Republican governor has stepped up
and said they're an important part of
our economy we want them to stay right
maybe you've know but you just you just
said I just want to get to the nub of it
though because I think it's a big deal I
mean once you legalize people they vote
that bring the relatives and it changes
the place maybe for the better maybe for
the worse but we should be clear about
the effects I think I think you'd agree
so if bringing in more people illegally
and making them citizens makes you more
prosperous then why wouldn't you bring
in ten million and become really really
rich would that work immigrants have
been amazing contributors to our
community if you look at some of the
data from forward us Mark Zuckerberg
organization so many of the
entrepreneurs who've built our tech
economy came here through immigration
and we in Phoenix are desperate for more
how many and how many big tech companies
are were started by people from Central
and South America Latin America so right
now I'm sitting in Phoenix Arizona very
close to a company called Fortis who was
that was started by a gentleman from
Panama it's one of our top engineering
companies in this community and they
actually are one of our largest
employers of at-risk veterans a
wonderful success I bet I bet he's a
great guy in the company's great but how
many big tech companies were started by
the immigrants that you're talking about
since you brought it up how many if you
I mean if you look at we've so many
success stories in this community and
some of them have gotten national
attention okay so I just want to be
smooth because it's a big with respect I
mean look I'm not attacking immigrants I
like immigrants I'm sure a lot of people
are great people but people who live
here who are born here or citizens have
a right to know the effects of this so
how many is the optimum number if
bringing in people illegally and giving
them citizenship makes you more
prosperous what's the number the ideal
number of people we should give
citizenship to our country in our
community was was built by immigration
okay and we have so many stories in this
community I know stories but I'm looking
for facts and I think it's fair to ask
for facts so John Lott who's a
researcher or social scientists got a
hold of the conviction numbers which the
government of the state of Arizona has
hidden from the population because it's
lying to the population about the
effects of immigration as you know and
he found that illegal immigrants in the
state of Arizona were more than twice as
likely to commit murder and overall far
more likely to commit crimes of all
kinds not immigration crimes but violent
and property crimes so given that those
are facts how can you reassure the
residents legal residents of Arizona of
all backgrounds that this is good for
them I don't understand we and cities
throughout our community have seen great
success stories when people feel like
they can work with the police department
and there's trust so we've had folks who
did not have legal immigration status
but we're willing to work with our
Police Department and have been very
important in helping us particularly
with drug-related crimes knowledge are
you do you acknowledge the reality of
what I just said so this study which got
a hold of Arizona State numbers which I
think are legitimate says that people
illegally in Arizona are far more likely
to commit serious crime do not believe
that are you just ignoring it or what's
your response to that so I just received
the arrest and crime data from the last
calendar year 2017 for the City of
Phoenix and that wasn't what we found in
the City of Phoenix
unfortunately violent crime was led by
people who live here and who that's not
that's not the question
were people who are there illegally more
likely or less likely to commit serious
crimes in the City of Phoenix are you
really saying they were less likely I
don't think that's what the numbers show
our 2017 numbers tell a very different
story than the story that that
researcher is telling you so were you
saying just to be totally clear we're
almost out of time are you saying that
you've seen numbers that in the City of
Phoenix people here illegally were less
likely to commit serious crimes than
citizens is that what you're saying I
just want to get you on the record
saying we need comprehensive immigration
reform oh oh you're slipping out of the
question I am asking a very simple
question you're not giving me a real
answer and I think that tells the whole
story thanks for joining us I appreciate
it